hello and welcome to our session this
session is intended for customers who
are new to cloudrun for anthos as well
as our existing customers who are
excited to learn what's new in the
product
i'm excited to walk us through our
agenda today including a demo of the new
capabilities of cloudrun for anthos that
we'll explore later in the presentation
i'm micah baker product manager for
cloud run for anth and i'm joined by my
colleague geno
hi i'm gina shah engineering manager at
google cloud my focus is building the
simplified developer experience on
manage and hybrid serverless compute
platforms i'm very excited to share
updates on cloudrun for anthos we have
been focused on bringing cloudrun for
anthos to all anthos platforms
uh mica
yeah i think for a lot of the customers
who are new to cloudon for anthos maybe
we should give a little bit of
background on what is cloud and for
anthos what makes it special and and
maybe some of the uh building blocks
could you tell us a little bit about uh
k native
yes absolutely so cloudrin for anthos is
built on top of k native what is gay
nature k native is an open source
platform with a very strong community
brings built-in learnings from google
and many other companies
so what values does it bring
so kubernetes is a raw power it's an
ubiquitous platform but it's not easy
for developers
k native was initial step adding
convenience and tooling built on top of
kubernetes it provides a developer
centric api to stand up scalable secure
stateless services in seconds
on top of that you run k native anywhere
kubernetes runs so you never have to
worry about vendor lock-in
so mica
yeah i love that explanation of k-native
thanks so much genoa
i think of cloudrun for anthos as like
the google supported managed k-native
uh it allows us to
uh give all the power of kubernetes that
you mentioned as well as the benefits of
k-native
uh but
further
create ease of use add more features to
it and bring that google support so it
also makes it possible for us to use
part of the anthos ecosystem as needed
for example we use antho service mesh
now which is our
managed version of open source istio
also because of anthos we can deploy
cloud run for anthos anywhere that antho
surface mesh can be installed so gives
us a lot of flexibility
enables these hybrid and multi-cloud
deployments that our customers have been
asking for
but
gino can you tell us a little bit about
how the developer experience in cloud
and for anthos relates back to that
k-native uh building block yes
absolutely
so what we are doing here is we are
delivering all the powers of kubernetes
along with developer-focused features of
k-native but without making developers
learn either technology cloud run for
and those abstract away all the complex
details of platform enabling developers
to focus on what matters that is writing
code and building applications
micah
that's that's a really great outcome for
our developers that they don't have to
become kubernetes experts or k-native
experts uh they can just focus on
development velocity um so i think it's
that's a really good background on like
what cloud run for anthos is uh maybe
before we continue just a quick pit stop
into what is anthos and how that antho
stack actually enables these outcomes
for developers
so i'll just explain a little bit about
anthos as
an abstraction of kubernetes so anthos
is a kubernetes platform that can run on
google cloud it can run on-prem and it
can also run on other cloud providers
and still have a single pane of glass
for a platform team to manage that
infrastructure
and then cloud infranthos runs on top of
anthos
further abstracting
kubernetes from the developers so it
creates a separation of concerns of
platform teams care about anthos that's
the platform they run and then the
developers care about cloud run for
anthos because that's uh their lens that
they see uh the cloud and on-prem
infrastructure through um gino could you
explain a little bit about uh how it
works for a developer a little bit about
what their a day in the life of a
developer would be
absolutely and i'm happy to share what
all features cloudrun
for anthos just comes out of the box
cloudren for anthos is tightly
integrated with cloud built that under
the covers uses industry standard cloud
native build pack specification that
allows you to build applications
directly from source code and deploy
you can also directly deploy your docker
containerized applications you know you
don't need to learn cube cuddle or k
native commands it is directly
integrated with gcloud
cli or google cloud
platform ui
the other features that i am really
passionate about
is talking about
gradual rollouts rollbacks and traffic
migrations and why i'm so excited
because it brings out of the box
google's sres best practices
cloudrun for androids allow you to roll
up new revisions of your applications or
services you perform a simple ap testing
canary testing by specifying which
division should receive what percentage
of traffic it allows you to roll back to
previous versions gradually roll out to
a revision or split traffic between
multiple revisions
and with this you can directly either
use our continuous deployment or
integrate that with your ci cd
it also comes tightly integrated with
cloud monitoring and cloud logging out
of the box it provides a metrics
collection dashboard so that you can
gain visibility into your performance
availability health of your services and
infrastructures
because it is it uses an open telemetry
agent it is possible to also send
metrics to any compatible third-party
monitoring solutions so we we have some
amazing features that comes right out of
the box
and
yeah we we will see some of this during
a demo over to you micah
well thanks gene i love that developer
experience and especially the focus on
it works out of the box but there are
also ways to customize i think that
really leads well into like what's in it
for the platform team uh the platform
teams get all the benefits of kubernetes
and the standards that it brings it's
just such a rich ecosystem for platform
teams using kubernetes
they can take advantage of the hardware
customization through kubernetes but not
have to worry about exposing that
complexity to the developers
there's lots of ways to configure and
manage kubernetes and make sure that
clusters are conformant to policies but
we don't need to expose any of the
yaml and other configuration scripts to
the developers
so
thanks to anthos and and kubernetes it's
possible for the platform teams to
target workloads wherever you need them
there might be uh latency sensitive
applications that need to be very close
to customers and so you might use
a mix of different providers to make
sure that you have uh your workloads
running as close to your users as
possible
but the developers don't have to think
about uh oh am i am i deploying my
workload in the in the correct provider
they just say i'm deploying my workload
and it can go automatically to the
correct places
um so i think that the the platform team
gets a full separation of the concerns
that they can focus on the platform and
then the developer team the application
team gets to have a separation of
concerns so that they can focus on just
the application logic and increasing
developer velocity
doing lots more av testing and handling
those rollbacks that you talked about
which sounds really exciting
i think it's a really good time for us
to
give a demo of some of these things
we've been talking about so uh i'd like
to switch us over to uh some of these
new features showing you uh what's
possible now that cloudrun for anthos
can be deployed on even more uh
destinations throughout anthos so let's
take a look
so we have several different anthos
clusters to showcase the hybrid and
multi-cloud deployment capabilities of
cloud river anthos
now the platform team has already
benefited from anthos by making it
possible to run these gke clusters
across clouds and on-prem so let's look
at the second half of our story to see
what the developer and operator operator
experience is on top of that
our demo starts just as we're finishing
rolling out the blue revision of our
blue green app and we just have one last
cluster to deploy to which is the gke on
aws cluster and that will complete the
initial rollout so we're doing things
manually for demo purposes but all the
things you're going to see here would be
part of continuous deployment if this
were a production workload so that means
that these services could be deployed to
all of the clusters simultaneously as
part of your delivery pipeline
so let's get started by
clicking this create service button
where we can manually select
a target for the service
in this case we're going to select that
gke on aws cluster we'll leave the
namespace as default
we'll call it
the same service as before
we'll deploy
the blue app revision and i'm also going
to set the minimum number of instances
to one that way this starts right away
and we have
an app that we can view as soon as it's
deployed
i'm going to click create
and now it's pulling down that container
image
so the app url um at the top mica if you
can uh highlight that
um yup so that app url at the top is
using the ip address of enthouse service
mesh ingress gateway with a simple dns
reflection service to provide a quick
way to test apps but for production our
customers would use their own custom
domain so mica can you talk about the
domain a little bit
yeah that's actually i appreciate that
call out genol the the services deployed
by cloud run for anthos
have this format uh that you'll see
consistently so it's broken up like this
first you see the service name in this
case it's blue green app
and then you'll see the name space that
we deployed to which is default and then
the last part of the url
is whatever your
domain would be so for production use
you would have some
actual domain name uh mapped here and
there's a there's a setting for you to
tell your clusters that all services
deployed should use your domain and not
the ip address that we're using here but
this is a quick and easy thing to do for
demo purposes uh you can just replace
imagine this being replaced with your
own
uh domain name if you're deploying this
into production
um
so it looks like our app is rolled out
let's let's click on that url then and
see what happened
we'll see what the uh this is the first
launch of the
pot so it'll go through that antho
service mesh ingress gateway that we set
up and
access that
blue revision of the blue green app that
we just deployed
and if everything is good we'll see a
blue app
and here it is the blue app is up and
running
and
everything looks good from an end user
perspective
so i'll close this and we'll go back
here
so now that we've rolled out the the
initial
revision that we were targeting which
was the blue app
we can go back to our services list and
we see that all of our clusters
for hybrid and multi-cloud
now have this initial
revision
but now we want to do an a b test with
our green app which is the cutting edge
new uh app in our blue green app product
and uh we're just going to jump back to
our gke cluster and it's just starting
this process
of deploying uh a new service again
but this time we're going to click this
edit and deploy new revision button at
the top since we have an existing
uh service already deployed we're going
to tell cloudrun for anthos that we'd
like to add something to it so in this
case we already had the blue app
container image i'm going to replace
that
with
the green app container image
and
is there anything else i need to change
gino
yeah so let's make sure to disable
automatic rollout so we can use traffic
splitting for granular control of the
traffic to our new revision
yep
that's the one
right here so
yeah we want to start off with zero
percent traffic to this since our intent
is an a b test
um
that will that will say create this
revision but we're not going to serve
anything right
all right let's deploy
and now it's grabbing that container
image
okay so that looked uh looked easy we
can use this manage traffic button
to control the traffic split and uh
notice that we're already serving 100
from the initial revision which was our
blue app
um
do you know what do you recommend for
this demo versus what we would do in
production for this traffic split
yeah so to to make it easier to see the
traffic splitting at work let's go with
50
to each revision uh what do you think
that sounds good uh
oh yeah look at that i i changed the new
one to 50 and automatically
balanced out the
percentages um
i love the like 50 50 is great because
uh for dental purposes of a blue green
app that we're doing that'll make it
really easy to see the traffic split but
um
yeah
yeah and for the production of course we
wouldn't recommend that and would
instead follow the google sre best
practices for the class of application
and potentially plan a five-day graduate
rollout that begins with one percent and
then graduates daily to larger
percentage
um
i appreciate the uh the call out to
google sre best practices which we are
certainly not following in this demo if
we jump straight to 50
uh if this was production traffic but um
this will be a great way for us to just
showcase uh this traffic splitting so
let's see what happened i'm going to
open up the
app and look we already got uh the green
app i'm going to refresh
and look at that this the first refresh
switched me to the blue app so both of
them are running and it's just
alternating between the two
uh as it randomly does a 50
uh split for any incoming request so
that's a pretty quick and easy way to do
any kind of a b tests
um
let's let's go back here then
uh do you know what do you think we
should do next since we it looks it
looks to me from an end user perspective
like the 50 split
is working is there anything else that
you you would want to check yeah so
let's look at the metrics and log to
confirm that what we see here we like it
and then
progress the rollout
yeah so
i i said it i just jumped right to a
one-hour view since that makes sense to
me of
uh what we've just been working on
um yeah
yeah so uh and can we also quickly um
um or michael can you quickly tell me
before we go to a different tab here
that how how are am i seeing this
metrics
uh the uh
i wish that i could claim that i built
this uh dashboard myself um but i
actually am happier to say that this was
just something that's built into the
product and it works out of the box so i
i could
um
i could do custom metrics and and
logging but this is actually uh cloud
monitoring and cloud logging working
right out of the box um so
that's pretty convenient for i can just
immediately see uh these key details of
my my apps
yeah and it has like all the basic
metrics um like you said micah that that
looks great um next can we jump too
quickly at logs and i want to see how my
green
app is doing
and if i see any error
or not
it looks like it's giving us success on
the most recent
deployment of this
so it seems like there are no obvious
issues so let's progress the rollout on
to the green app 200 percent
okay
that sounds good uh so i'm using that
same managed traffic button that i used
before
um
we're gonna just type in 100 here and it
automatically takes the blue app to zero
so i'm just gonna click save get my
changes
and
there looks like that's done let's go
back uh let's go verify this uh
this should no longer show blue so if i
refresh i expect yup now it's green i'll
refresh a few more times
i'm getting nothing but green it's super
green
okay
that looks like uh
success to me uh that was a really fun
experience um i didn't even have to be a
kubernetes ninja to do any of this
um i was able to
just use this interface to accomplish my
goals and not really think about the
kubernetes part of it
yep so that's the experience we were
targeting with cloudrun for anthos mica
and it's a possible uh to break a glass
and customize things um but it's also a
great experience right out of the box
that's great so the platform team gets
all this value from anthous at the
platform level
and the application team gets this
additional value from cloud for anthos
at the application level uh that sounds
like a pretty great combination
um that concludes the demo
if you'd like to learn more about cloud
run for anthos please visit any of the
links listed here we're excited to help
both our existing customers and new
customers continue their journey into
kubernetes with anthos and cloud run for
anthos
it's been my pleasure
to talk to you
and have this discussion about the
exciting new features in cloud run for
anthos
uh also thank you so much gino for uh
sharing this time with me
um thank you micah and thank you viewers
for tuning in i hope you enjoy rest of
your next 2021. thank you